pour les enquêteurs russes cela ne fait
aucun doute le crime a été soigneusement
planifié la bombe qui a tué daria
douguine a été placée sous la voiture du
côté du conducteur la très conservatrice
chaîne de télévision sarr grade où elle
travaillait comme journaliste et
éditorialiste lui a rendu hommage notre
ami alliés personnes partageant les
mêmes idées daria douguine a été tué
d'une façon lâche et ville pour tenter
de nous faire souffrir le plus possible
nous peuple russe patriotes et impériaux
malgré sa jeunesse derrière douguine à
était une véritable guerrière russe
souvenir éternel et lumineux selon le
média d'état tu as douguine à rentrer
dans la capitale russe après avoir
assisté à un festival avec son père
alexandre douguine c'est lui qui était
visé selon ses proches mais il aurait
décidé de changer de voiture au dernier
moment l'idéologue ultranationaliste a
longtemps plaidé pour l'unification des
territoires russophone il a popularisé
des concepts comme la nova la cia ou
nouvelle russie pour justifier
l'annexion de la crimée en 2014 sa fille
et lui étaient de fervents défenseurs de
la guerre en ukraine et figurait sur la
liste des sanctions américaines le chef
de la région séparatiste de donetsk a
accusé kiev d'avoir orchestré
l'explosion un scénario peu probable
pour cet analyste
je ne pense pas que l'ukraine ait quoi
que ce soit et gagner ils ne peuvent pas
se permettre d'être dépeint comme des
terroristes s'étaient pas leur style je
pense ce n'est pas parce que ce sont les
gentils ou quelque chose comme ça c'est
parce que ça ne sert tout simplement pas
leurs objectifs
les autorités ukrainiennes nie toute
implication
pour un conseiller du président hélène
ski l'attentât pourrait avoir été
perpétré par des factions politiques
russes